[Music]
and
every society is oil of control,
controlling citizens in
communist society is of course
characterized by these means,
but in American society that
illusion of freedom that
Cubans often see as looking at freedom is on
the side there is not  it's real
in my mentality it's a
better hippie communist mentality it's a bit strange
but it works for me it works for me because I
'm like that
they had the mission of ribas and
rescues in general
the role of where there are managers the great
fair music hashish they
don't let you have all  these things you
wanted seven months have passed and they
have agreed with me and the problem you
have is because of the room I wanted to
talk
[Music]
yes he has changed a lot
twenty years when I have made a lot of
relationships but I still depend on people who
come from outside and bring materials
[Music]
we have very fat
enormous in terms of technology and
information media industry of the
entire city is totally destroyed  The
infrastructure of the country is very bad, they
need a lot of time
to fix it, children, and we have spent more
time with many people. We don't have
[Music]
why
yes
[Music]
I couldn't in Havana I'm coming to the
mountains
the only mail in  the phone and it can
receive some photos also sometimes
but the lights download very badly
and you can have internet in the Wi-Fi sites
that are being enabled for it they
are starting now you do
but it is not so easy nor has it started very
recently  that the
wi-fi internet is done in action two tall prisoners
and not much
look not around here everything is possible
with the changes definitely the
distance between the rich and the poor
is going to increase a lot it is going to be
much bigger although I don't think it will
I got to the point on the list
too much I don't think and it's been a long time but it's
still going to happen
in fact you can still see those
changes you can already see the difference between
rich and poor
for  that there are people who can go to a bar and
even get the entire month's salary of
a worker in a single night in drinks and
there are people who cannot go in because it
seems that their life
[Music]
until very recently until 34 years ago
years they cannot sell their house they are not
legally enough and all that changed a
long time ago so there are companies that
are dedicated in real estate like 20 and
purchases to represent sellers
to buyers and these examples are
selling and
[Music]
90 miles
we take degrees
25 months
[Music]
What bothers me the most is also the use of
the figure of Che Guevara,
not because of people, they don't even know who the man was.
I do things my
way and now it works my way what I
know there has to be a society
where people who are different are tolerated
and where people are allowed to
choose in the way they want to live
than in the society to which  we live
right now
but our country has many good things,
our society has many
good things that I don't want to
lose with this change
[Music]
I get up
but today I want
[Music]